DULY ELECTED 45TH PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
TIME TO FACE HIM TRUTH.
JOINING US NOW, AUTHOR OF THE
NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER "THE
RUSSIAN HOAX, THE ILLICIT'S
CLAIM TO FREE HILLARY CLINTON
AND FRAME DONALD TRUMP."
ALONG WITH INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER SARA CARTER.
WE BEGIN WITH YOU, JOHN
SOLOMON'S REPORT FROM TONIGHT,
THIS IS NOW CONCRETE EVIDENCE,
THE FBI WAS TOLD EVERYTHING
ABOUT CHRISTOPHER STEELE WHO
PAID FOR THE RUSSIAN DIRT
DOSSIER LIES AND THEY THEN USED
IT ANYWAY.
TO SPY IN SPITE OF WHAT JAMES
COMEY SAYS.
>> IT WAS TO SPY, AND WHAT IS
WORSE IS THE FACT THAT THE FBI
WAS WELL AWARE OF WHAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS UP TO AND
DOING, THE FACT THAT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE HIMSELF HAD ADMITTED TO
THE DEPUTY ASSISTANT SECRETARY
OF STATE AT THE TIME THAT HE WAS
GOING TO RELEASE THE INFORMATION
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THIS IS CERTAINLY TO TARGET A
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP AND THEN
EVENTUALLY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
REMEMBER AFTER THEY GET TO THE
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT TO SPY ON
CARTER PAGE, WHICH THEY DID NOT
DISCLOSE TO THE COURT, ALL OF
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY HAD.
AND WHERE THE INFORMATION CAME
FROM, AND THE FACT THAT HALF OF
IT WAS LIVES, THEY CONTINUE TO
SPY ON CARTER PAGE, RENEWING IT
FOR FOUR TIMES DURING THE 2016
AND 2017 ALL THE WAY TO THE
FALL.
THE LAST ONE BEING SIGNED BY ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
SO WHAT JOHN BROKE IS SO
SIGNIFICANT AND SO IMPORTANT, IT
WILL UNLEASH THE AVALANCHE,
BECAUSE NOW THEY WILL HAVE TO
EXPLAIN WHY THEY DID THIS.
AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY SPYING.
WHEN YOU CONCOCT A TAIL TO
ACTUALLY LOOK INTO OTHER
PEOPLE'S EMAILS, LISTEN INTO
THEIR TELEPHONE CONVERSATIONS
AND TRY TO SET UP A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: THE AVALANCHE THAT IT
KEEPS SAYING, COMING CASCADING
DOWN.
GREGG JARRETT, THIS IS BUT A
SMALL PART.
WE HAVE OF COURSE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ON
FIVES ABUSE.
WE NOW HAVE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT WILL LOOK INTO HILLARY'S
RIGGED INVESTIGATION.
WE WILL HAVE THE HOOVER REPORT
ON LEAKED MATERIALS BUT WE WILL
HAVE 302, WE WILL HAVE GANG OF
EIGHT, WE WILL HAVE THE FISA
APPLICATIONS THEMSELVES.
MUELLER IS DEAD.
WHETHER PEOPLE CAN FACE THE
TRUTH OR NOT, NOW ACT TWO, THE
CURTAIN IS UP.
>> AND JOHN'S DOCUMENTARY
EVIDENCE NOW PROVES CONCLUSIVELY
THAT JAMES COMEY WAS LYING TO
THE FISA CORD.
AND ON CNN, YOU PLAY THE CLIP
THAT HE SAID HE WENT BY THE
BOOK.
THAT IS ALSO A LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
JAMES COMEY IS NOW SWINGING
THESE WILD HAY MAKERS, BECAUSE
HE KNOWS THAT VERY SOON --
>> Sean: DOES HE?
>> HE IS GOING DOWN ON THE
CAMPUS FOR A TEN COUNT.
HE IS IN A DEEP SERIOUS LEGAL
JEOPARDY.
FOR LYING TO A FISA CORD,
LEAKING GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS
THAT HE STOLE, STARTING AN
INVESTIGATION WITHOUT CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE, SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, AND MAKING FALSE
STATEMENTS TO CONGRESS.
I HOPE THAT HE SAVED ALL OF THE
MONEY THAT HE MADE FROM THAT
PHONY BOOK OF HIS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT "LIARS AND
LYING PEOPLE."
BECAUSE HE WILL NEED THE MONEY
FOR HIS DEFENSE TEAM.
>> Sean: GREGG JARRETT, REMIND